go now lied to a police press conference
about the dog attack in Milton Keynes
that killed four-year-old Alice stones
so I'm superintendent Mark tarbert and
I'm the police Commander for Milton
Keynes and I'm really saddened to be
talking to you under such tragic
circumstances today
so I'll run through the facts as we
currently know them and then I'll
provide some updates
so just after 5 PM yesterday afternoon
officers were called to a property in
Broadlands in netherfield where it's
reported that a child had been attacked
by a dog in a back Garden
medical staff attended the location but
sadly a four-year-old girl the girl was
pronounced dead at the scene
formal identification has not yet taken
place
and our thoughts are with her family and
friends at this difficult time
the child's family are being supported
by specially trained officers and we'd
ask that their privacy is respected
an investigation is currently underway
to fully understand the circumstances
but we currently believe that this was a
tragic isolated incident and there is no
threat to the wider community
accordingly no arrests have been made at
this time
I can confirm that the dog was a family
pet and was put down by police police at
the scene yesterday evening
and part of the investigation is to
establish the breed of that dog
while our investigation takes place
there will be more offices in the area
over the coming days
this is clearly an incident that has
shocked and upset people and I urge
residents to speak to offices with any
questions or concerns they may have
I'd also like to ask the community for
their support in not speculating about
this matter
and offer reassurance that our
detectives are working hard to progress
the investigation and you can contact us
if you have any information
I'll share further updates when we have
them
and thank you
our superintendent Mark tarbet there um
giving a short statement in Milton
Keynes
after the death of Alice Stone's the
little girl pictured they're just four
years old killed by a dog in the back
Garden of a house in Milton Keynes an
investigation is underway to understand
the circumstances surrounding her death
you had the superintendent there say
that the dog involved was a family pet
it has been put down the breed not yet
established he also spoke about the
concerns in the community he said that
it is believed to be a tragic isolated
incident but of course the police are
there for support let's bring the skies
after her now she's at the scene has
been following this story as it has
unfolded Asha this is just such a tragic
case
um poor little Alice Stones there and
the police just you know reminding the
community that's important not to
speculate at this stage this is still an
ongoing investigation
yeah superintendent Mark tarbert there
from Thames Valley police explaining to
us that now their main task is to try
and establish the breed of this dog we
learned that this was indeed a family
pet confirming what friends and
neighbors had told us earlier on inside
the house that's literally right across
the road from this church next to me
inside that property live four-year-old
Alice Stones alongside her mother Louise
and we know now that this was a family
pet which committed this horrendous
attack on four-year-old Alice killing
her yesterday paramedics came to the
scene just after five o'clock last night
and little Alice was pronounced dead at
the scene we've been speaking to people
here today all day understandably they
are absolutely devastated and
heartbroken too because this came as
such an awful shock
um what we heard there from this
superintendent was that this was an
isolated incident in that he meant that
once police had established that this
was the dog that committed this attack
police officers then went on to put that
dog down of course they will now try to
establish where exactly this dog came
from where was it sourced from it's
understood that the family didn't have
this dog for very long some saying that
they had it for a few weeks some for a
little bit less than that but everyone
we've spoken to said there is just such
a sense of shock because they couldn't
believe that this family pet was capable
of such a thing we've managed to see
some home videos of little Alice that
have been provided to us and in it you
can see such a happy smiling giggling
young four-year-old just like any any
other four-year-old there are videos of
her playing in the park nearby with her
mother and she's playing playing it
alongside her friends and she just seems
so so happy and giggling and the fact is
no one could have predicted that such an
awful incident would have happened today
outside played the property there's been
a significant police presence still as
you'd be able to imagine there were
police guarding both The Cordon at the
front of the house and at the back and
we've also seen a forensic tent put up
at the back of the property because it's
thought this incident happened in the
family's Back Garden
and this morning we could see keys left
in the front door curtains that hadn't
been drawn windows that were still open
such as the sense of franticness in
which this incident unfolded barely 24
hours ago but really thoughts here
within this community are with the
family at the center of it all and those
who knew four-year-old Alice stones